I'll be very brief thanks miroslav and
good to see you all across the globe
there let me start with a distinction
not very different from thick versus
thin that comes from the psychologist
and philosopher William James who
distinguished acute and chronic religion
acute religion is identity defining and
demands to subordinate other forms of
knowledge to religious doctrine or dogma
and chronic religion is more porous and
more penetrable by other ideas the
thought I have is that acute religion
combined with certain external
circumstances is the most dangerous
combination and those external
circumstances would be poverty isolation
government which is undemocratic and
authoritarian or wholly inept as in
failed States illiteracy and early
stages in the world demographic
transition that is stages where you have
disproportionately large numbers of
young people in a population and low
expectations of life span if you look at
vitamin violence which is not
institutionally organized the vast
majority of it comes from very young men
and that combination is is I think think
particularly dangerous I teach in the
business school and I therefore like to
believe that commerce is a good thing
voltaire centuries ago put forward the
proposition that
muhammadans Jews Christians and Hindus
who meet in a stock exchange learn to
tolerate one another and learn to have a
certain sense of ironic detachment about
their religious differences and I think
actually the process of globalization
has within it the potential to promote
this more ironic chronic attitude toward
religious dogma and I'll stop there